one of the habits that I highly
encourage you do is that every morning
what's the first thing you check is it
Instagram is it YouTube is it your text
I'll tell you the first thing that I
checked with my bank account every day I
would wake up and I'll check my bank
account and what happens when you do
that is you develop this muscle of kind
of this understanding of the money flow
it's just like weight loss if you get on
a scale every day and you're trying to
lose weight and you don't do jack
but you literally just get on the scale
every day people lose weight drawing and
putting awareness to the problem or the
thing that you're trying to change
improves it and the first thing in the
day priority it means it is happening
prior it's more important so you wake up
you make money a priority you check your
bank account every day you look at all
of the pluses that go in you look at all
the minuses and next month you try and
make that column go up and that column
go down I don't want to be poor I'm
going to look at this money until
eventually it starts paying attention
back to me because money sticks to the
person who pays it the most attention